so uh i was saying thank you very much
ambassador zhang
mr president
it is indeed a great pleasure
to have this opportunity to brief the
council on the situation
at the nuclear facilities in ukraine
as the council knows the iaea has been
actively assessing the situation in
these facilities
since
the
war conflict began back in february and
you may recall that i had the
opportunity to report on the state of
affairs to you
back in march
since
february 24
the iaea has activated its incident and
emergency center
established regular contact with the
ukrainian authorities and closely
monitored the situation at this
facilities as well as activities
involving
radioactive sources and nuclear material
in ukraine
i have issued
frequent almost daily
updates
on the
website to ensure that everyone
personally
led uh two missions
to provide assistance
um to ukraine
one at the south ukraine nuclear power
plant in march and subsequently a second
one at the to the chernobyl
site in april
the agency has also been coordinating
offers of assistance
from our member states and facilitated
the provision
of equipment and radiation such as
personal protection equipment or
radiation
monitors
in total up to now 12
member states have offered assistance
the agency myself been in frequent
contact with both ukraine and the
russian federation to make sure we have
the clearest
picture
possible of the evolving circumstances
at this site
we have the agency has conducted nine
safeguards missions in ukraine at the
south ukraine nuclear power plant the
rivne
nuclear power plant kennitsky
and the chernobyl site
and keith
area
which are under
iaea
safeguards pursuant to the npt
comprehensive safeguards agreement that
the agency has with ukraine
these
on-site inspections have enabled the
agency to fulfill its
obligatory safeguards objectives
remote
monitoring from iaea headquarters
of other nuclear power plants and the
chernobyl
area remain ongoing
most recently i've i have had two
teams at the chernobyl site
performing critical safeguards
velification activities
the two expert missions to ukraine which
i have led personally as i said allowed
us to see for ourselves the situation on
the ground and provide technical
assistance which has been already a
given and its own goal
there are of course a number of
humanitarian political and legal issues
which are the
limit of the security council and but
our work
as you know uh very well
focused exclusively on technical issues
related to the safety the security and
the inspections the safeguards
inspections
in ukraine
earlier in the year and i had also an
opportunity to recall this
just
a little more than a week ago when i was
addressing the ongoing
npt review conference
there in new york
i outlined
a number of
indispensable pillars seven of them
which are cardinal which are crucial to
ensure
safety and security
these include i will not enumerate them
all but they include in general crucial
aspects dealing with the physical
integrity obviously the physical
integrity of the plant
the off-site power supply which as you
know is indispensable for a nuclear
plant for cooling systems to work
emergency preparedness
measures and systems and so on
the thing is that all these seven
pillars have been compromised
if not entirely
violated at one point or the other
during this ongoing crisis
legally speaking when it comes to
attacks or the possibility of attacks on
nuclear facilities we are of course
not working on a vacuum the
international community has taken a
stance very early on
against this type of thing and the
additional protocols one and two through
the 1949
geneva conventions prohibit such attacks
against um nuclear
electrical as it was said back in the
day generating stations in armed
conflict and on top of that there have
been a number of uh
general
uh general conference
resolutions from the iaea
so all of this is a framework that
must be observed
we all we're all aware and perhaps this
meeting and this briefing takes place
against the backdrop of this
recently the situation at the nuclear
facilities and in particular at the
separation nuclear power plant in
ukraine have been deteriorating rapidly
to the point of becoming
very
alarming
on
fifth august
the separation nuclear power plant was
subject to shelling
resulting in several explosions several
explosions within the site of a nuclear
power plant
these explosions took place near the
electrical switchboard
of a 750 kilowatt external
power supply that cause
the
shutdown of the electrical power
transformer and two backup transformers
consequently one reactor unit was shut
down and disconnected from the
electrical grid
so you can see there is a direct link
between
these external interventions attacks and
what's happening at the planet
the emergency protection
system of the affected unit
was triggered
and diesel generators were set into
operation
to ensure the power supply of this unit
this unit
as we speak
remain disconnected from the grid
there was also shelling in the area of
the nitrogen
oxygen station at the plant
firefighters
quickly extinguished this fire
however
repairs
must be assessed evaluated and
done
on august 6 1 staff member of sapolicia
working in the area of the dry spent
nuclear fuel storage facility in the
facility was injured during a new
episode of shelly which also caused some
physical damage
additionally ukraine has reported to us
that sabrina's staff have restricted
access to the on-site emergency crisis
center
as of today
the san paulistia nuclear power plant
has limited
availability
of off-site power
one
external high voltage line and one high
voltage backup line to the thermal plant
due to the damage of the shelling
from the shelling
that i just referred
in in particular i remain
very concerned about the situation of
the separation nuclear power plant and i
reiterate that any
military action
deopolizing nuclear safety
nuclear security
must stop immediately
these military actions
dear colleagues near such a large
nuclear facility
could lead to very serious consequences
even before
these most recent events i had already
expressed
great concern
about the extremely stressful and
difficult conditions faced by the
ukrainian operating staff
the the agency
continues
to monitor the situation
to identify any potential implication
that could arise at the facilities based
on the most recent information i.e
experts have preliminary
have preliminary assessed that there is
no
immediate threat to nuclear safety as a
result of the shelling
or other military actions
however
this
could change
at
any moment
we certainly can all agree
that any
nuclear catastrophe would be
unacceptable
and therefore preventing it
should be
our overarching goal
we must all work together to prevent it
that is our duty
that is our common responsibility
in order to help achieve that
i ask that both sides
cooperate
with the ieee and allow
for a mission
to the saporia nuclear power plant to
proceed as soon as possible
this huge facility you are aware it has
been said many times
is
currently
in russian occupied territory so it
cannot
be reached by traveling
exclusively
through ukrainian controlled territory
we have worked and we need to work
pragmatically
with authorities of both countries
in efforts to obtain access
for our experts
to support
i am personally ready to lead such a
mission
as i did
for south ukraine
and chernobyl
leading a team of experts from the iaea
we have been preparing for this and time
is of the essence
so i propose i plead
to hold this mission as soon as possible
mr president
since the installation
has been under the control of russia
the iaea has received information from
russia as well as from ukraine
indicating the state
of the facility
its operation
and the damage assessment
however
however
the contents of such statements
are
frequently
contradictory
and without
i repeat
without a physical presence
the iaea
cannot corroborate
some very important facts
it is those facts
gathered during a site visit
that are needed
so that the ieee
may be able
to develop and provide an independent
assessment of the nuclear safety and
security risks
among other critical activities
what are we intending to
do we would assess
the physical damage to the facilities
we will determine
whether the main and backup
safety and security systems are
functional
and evaluate
the working conditions
of the control room staff
the mission to the site will also allow
us
to perform urgent
safeguards activities
verifying the status of the reactors
and the inventories
of nuclear material
including
fresh and spent fuel storage
where we currently have
no remote data transfer
of surveillance
furthermore
we need to perform maintenance
on all iaea safefirst equipment in order
to ensure the remote
data transmission
and the
maintenance of continuity of knowledge
which is indispensable
after
leaving the facility
not only
would a mission to separation beneficial
to the work of the iaea and to the
assessment of the international
community of what is going on
but i believe i am convinced it would be
beneficial to the operators and the
regulators of the nuclear plant
the previous iaea missions which i have
mentioned on a couple of occasions
to south ukraine and chernobyl
were
a proof
that being there establishing the facts
is what is needed at the moment
overall
i also believe that our own site
presence
will both allow us to carry the
technical activities that i have just
described
and also provide a stabilizing
stabilizing influence
i want to underscore that the iaea has
been ready to perform such a mission
since june
when we were ready to go
but unfortunately due to political
factors and other considerations it was
not possible
we've seen what has happened
over the past two months we cannot allow
such factors to delay us
any longer
i reiterate
the military actions that have even the
smallest potential
to jeopardize nuclear safety
or nuclear security
at such a nuclear installation must stop
immediately
these actions could lead us to serious
consequences
the iaea
is ready to help avert such an
escalation of the crisis
i want to thank
the
security secretary general
who has been steadfast in his support to
our mission i had an opportunity
to discuss with him a few days ago in
new york i have followed his statements
of support without which
our work would be tremendously more
difficult
and i thank the security council for
having given me this opportunity
to state
some facts
and to also reiterate
that this is a serious our great power
and the iaea must be allowed to conduct
its mission to separation as soon as
possible i thank you
raphael
[Music]
steps the consequences of which would
reverberate far beyond the borders of
ukraine
unfortunately that is what is now
happening
on nuclear infrastructure pushing the
world to the brink of nuclear
catastrophe
pipelines were destroyed and a hydrogen
combustion incident at the hub took
place a high voltage power line was also
knocked out
i would like to underscore that
ukrainian armed forces are shelling the
plant and shelter plant during the shift
clearly
to undermine the normal functioning
and also an automated radiation
monitoring
disconnecting of the power lines
energy unit number four which was
working at 10 capacity
the electricity supply for the nuclear
power plant protection management system
was knocked out and the emergency
protection system was triggered by
ukrainian staff the nuclear power plant
were forced to suspend the operation of
one of the three remaining energy blocks
and the capacity of the remaining two
was reduced to 50 percent of maximum
mass strikes by the ukrainian forces on
the outskirts
led to
the
were carried out at night while people
were sleeping
rocket systems and heavy artillery from
the right bank of the nearby river from
the territory of nepal petroleum
has aimed its weapons at the concrete
storage facilities of radioactive waste
for the time being they have not been
able to hit them and do serious damage
the background radiation at the nuclear
power plant is within limits but if the
strikes continue it is only a question
of time
regularly sent to the iaea secretariat
information bulletins with a detailed
outline of the situation uh and these
incidents
mr president
has been taking place in the last few
days of the nuclear power plant is the
combination of the criminal actions of
the kiev regime against nuclear
infrastructure and the staff serving
those facilities which uh for months has
gone without any international reaction
in the period from april to july have
carried out a number of provocations
against the nuclear power plant with the
use of drones
including drones made in
functioning of the plant previously in
february ukrainians seized all russian
specialists who were accompanying a
supply of nuclear fuel to the
nuclear power plant
they were intimidated and put pressure a
professional in line with the
traditional methods used by terrorist
groups
of march ukrainian saboteurs blew up a
power line feeding the cooling system
for the spent nuclear fuel storage
facility at the chernobyl nuclear power
plants
of the russians
diesel generators and ensuring the
supply of electricity to the plant
through an alternative power line from
the territory of
blew up the only belarus that connected
the plant with the town housing
personnel the replacement ship for a
long time was not able to come to work
in parallel with it they were processed
by the ukrainian special forces who were
threatening them with reprisals for
cooperating with the occupied and in
kiev at the same time they were publicly
shedding crocodile tears and reporting
to the iaea saying that russian forces
were preventing the rotation of these
shifts in the plantation station in new
york
these propaganda attacks are being
seized
all of this is being done contrary to
common sense because the nuclear power
plant is controlled by russian armed
forces
elementary logic would suggest that our
soldiers would have no reason to shell
either the plant or the town or
themselves even
as the actions of russian forces even
though this the plant at the time was
under their full control
i would remind you that back then under
secretary general
said that attacks on nuclear facilities
were a violation of international
humanitarian law the representative of
the united kingdom said that
international law pointed to the need
for particular protection for nuclear
facilities
are you prepared to repeat all of that
now as applies to the actions of the
ukrainian side and call on kiev to stop
the shelling
i would like to underscore that each
time the ukrainian armed forces launched
strikes on a nuclear power plant a
disaster was avoided only thanks to the
selfless
joint work of the plant workers and the
russian service personnel who provided
them with comprehensive emergency
support when necessary fire and accident
personnel and also our service personnel
hand in hand this clearly indicates that
between our soldiers and ukrainian
specialists there is absolutely normal
communication
mr president from the very outset we've
supported the efforts of the iaea to
ensure the nuclear and physical nuclear
security of nuclear facilities in
ukraine
as well without providing any clear
arguments or reasons for rejecting it
and we do everything that we can to
ensure that representatives of the
agency can see this with their own eyes
on the third of jesus
russia and the leadership of the iaea
secretariat fully agreed on the route
and scheduled for the movement
as
um what is such a difficult but such a
necessary activity in these conditions
however at the last minute the red light
was given by the un department of safety
and security
trip was cancelled and that was received
upon by the key of authorities to step
up their provocations and shelling of
the nuclear plants we're convinced that
cancelling the international
or any other links in the un's mechanism
do anything to hinder the conduct of
this mission
all possible assistance to resolving all
organizations
we believe is
as quickly as possible and possibly even
before the end of august
far from everything
there are no guarantees that the trip
will take
place currently provide it's hard for us
to judge what is currently being cooked
up by the ukrainian leadership
uh which for several days in a row has
been launching strikes on the nuclear
power plant even though the u.n
secretary general described any attacks
on nuclear facilities as a
suicide we believe it is unacceptable
that the iaea's mission should take
place in the conditions of continuing
ukrainian armed forces shelling of the
plant and the territory around the town
of
kiev must immediately cease and
guarantee
the absence of intentions to present any
threat to the life and health of
internationals
we call on states that support the care
to bring their proxies into check
compel them to immediately
stop attacks
without any diplomatic simulations to
indicate the real source of the threat
to nuclear security
strikes from the ukrainian armed forces
and to tell the ukrainian authorities
that these actions are unacceptable this
is the only way to prevent a major
radiation catastrophe on the european
continent the risk of which is now more
real than ever yes
ukrainian
attacks continue this could take place
at any time
the threat of radiation contamination
would move over the territories of kiev
bulgaria and romania
thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for his statement and
now give the floor to the representative
of ghana
thank you mr president let me begin by
thanking mr rafael grossi dieter general
of the iaea for his briefing on the
deeply concerning situation at the
zapoisian nuclear power plant in ukraine
the information provided confirms our
fears of a growing risk of a potential
nuclear incident with catastrophic
consequences for human lives and the
environment if the indiscriminate
sharing of the facility does not cease
forthwith
ghana unequivocally condemns the
militarization of the presence of
zaporizia nuclear power plant as well as
the deliberate attacks on the power
lines and sensitive units of the
facility
it appears that the attacks are taking
place with no due regard to the deadly
consequences that these unacceptable
actions could lead to particularly the
accidental emissions of radioactive
material
we also call for the unconditional
withdrawal a removal of all military
personnel and equipment and insist on
the return of the facility to its
accredited personnel
we welcome the public pronouncement of
secretary general antonio guterres
regarding the rapidly developing grave
situation
and hereby fully endorses its call for
an immediate asset to be granted to
international inspectors from the iaea
to enable an independent assessment of
the nuclear facility standards and
safeguards of the facility
under no circumstances through nuclear
facilities intended for peaceful
purposes be subjected to such attacks we
call for the immediate and full respect
for the convention on the fiscal
protection of nuclear material and its
2005 amendment by all the armed parties
mr president the world can ill afford
another nuclear disaster we cannot
forget too soon the horrors of the 8
1986 chernobyl accident and the
consequent nuclear catastrophe which
left in its wake long-term effects of
radiation exposure to many people in
ukraine and parts of europe even to date
the warnings of the iaea must therefore
be soberly reflected on by this council
and should galvanize us to quickly
deploy every effort in a unified manner
to assist the iaea to mitigate and
suppress any risk of accidental
emissions at the zaporizia nuclear
facility
ghana believes that ultimately the
cessation of the military hostilities
anchored in a complete and unconditional
withdrawal of the troops of russian
federation from the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine is the
only acceptable pathway to the
restoration of the peace and security of
ukraine
in this regard we continue to strongly
edge a pacifist settlement of the
substantive security concerns of the
parties in line with the charter and
appeal to all other actors to refrain
from escalatory actions and activities
that only seeks to prolong the war
perpetrate the tensions and aggravate
the security concerns of the parties
mr president as the senseless war
lingers on civilians are bearing
innumerable hardships and human lives
are being lost daily it is important for
the parties to exercise restraint and
halt the use of force in all areas of
critical infrastructure including the
nuclear power plants and to respect
their international obligations to
protect human lives and to prevent a
potential disaster
admittedly the war in ukraine continues
to have devastating consequences beyond
the battlefield the rippling effects
combined with economic disruptions
caused by the covet-19 pandemic have
contributed to constrain the fiscal
space of many governments and led to
spiraling food prices which
threatens to push millions into acute
hunger and roll back development gains
the situation of developing countries
appears to be dire and require urgent
actions on a global scale including that
forgiveness and restructuring to assist
them navigate their current volatile
global economic environment in order to
preserve their stability
it is hoped that this council together
with the international community could
explore new support measures and
appropriate responses to protect
vulnerable populations in member states
i conclude by expressing ghana's strong
support for the peaceful resolution of
this conflict sooner than later we urge
further constructive engagement by the
parties at all levels in the pursuit of
their security interests and the
maintenance of international peace and
security i thank you
okay
i thank the representative for her
statement
i now give the floor
to under secretary of arms control and
international security of the united
states of america miss bonnie jenkins
thank you director general grossi for
your briefing on the situation at the
zepharisia nuclear power plant in
ukraine
we welcome the iea steadfast commitment
to addressing the situation there
and to nuclear safety worldwide
the united states continues to closely
monitor reports
regarding the situation at the
zephyristic facility
noting considerable concern regarding
the risk of a nuclear incident that
would endanger the people of ukraine
neighboring states
and the international community
the cause of the situation at the
zephyricia facility is not a mystery
it is another tragic result
of the russian federation's decision to
further invade its sovereign neighbor
ukraine
russia's full-scale invasion has
resulted in thousands of civilians
killed or wounded to date
and has violated the u.n charter and the
principles of international law
the full-scale invasion has also
contributed to a spike
in global food insecurity
driven energy market volatility
and now heighten the risk of a
catastrophic nuclear incident with
consequences that could be felt in
ukraine and far beyond
it is especially garlic
that russia's actions are taking place
during the ongoing review conference of
the nuclear nonproliferation treaty
being held just down the hall from where
we sit
russia's behavior could not more
directly undercut the shared interests
of the state's parties in strengthening
non-proliferation
disarmament
and peaceful uses of nuclear energy
the solution for what is happening at
the zephyrism facility is
straightforward
the united states calls for the russian
federation
to immediately withdraw its forces from
ukraine's territory
this would allow for ukraine to restore
the impeccable safety
security and safeguards performance it
upheld for decades at the facility
russia continues to deploy
disinformation to distract from the
realities on the ground
and now claims that ukraine is culpable
for the situation at the zanfarisia
facility
this completely ignores the real issue
which is russia's illegal presence at
the facility russia alone created risks
and when it launched a full-scale
invasion
and it could eliminate those risks now
by withdrawing from ukraine
in the absence of such withdrawal
however there are steps we must take now
to minimize the risks
to start
the united states reiterates the
importance of facilitating access for
iaea personnel
to address nuclear safety security and
safeguards concerns
at the zafaricia facility
as well as at other nuclear facilities
around the country
in a manner that respects ukrainian
sovereignty this visit cannot wait any
longer
we once again call on russia to cease
all military operations at or near
ukraine's nuclear facilities
and insist that russia immediately
return
full control of the zephyrisia facility
to ukraine
we are also aware of claims of
mistreatment of the power plants
ukrainian staff by russian soldiers and
note that if true
such treatment would be inconsistent
with the iea 7 pillars of nuclear safety
and security which russia has endorsed
ukrainian staff must be allowed to
fulfill their important duties
free from the pressure of russia's armed
forces
the united states also supports
ukraine's proposal to create a
demilitarized zone around the zafareshia
plant
reports such as that by the iaea we
heard today
underscore the urgency of the situation
but what is happening at this nuclear
power plant is not the only alarming
situation we face
in the areas where russia's forces
operate in ukraine
russia has expanded its aims in ukraine
and seeks to dismantle it as a
geopolitical entity
dissolving it from the world map
we are now getting a clearer picture of
what life is like in an area under
russian military control
through intimidation
censorship and propaganda
russia is clearly laying the foundation
to try
once again
to legally annex territory from its
neighbor
none of us should be surprised if russia
subtly announces false referenda in
these regions as a pretext to grabbing
more of ukraine's sovereign territory
the many consequences of this conflict
including the situation at the zephyrian
nuclear power plant will only end when
russia ends this war
today the united states demands
particularly urgent action
to address the nuclear risks posed by
russia's latest moose
this must be done through the work of
the iaea
and a return of full control of the
zafarisha facility to ukraine
thank you
perpetuation
parties
the scale
we urge the parties to comply with
current
nuclear security rules
my country calls on the party
any type of military activity
in this regard
an iaea technical mission to the site
seems crucial
in the parties
[Music]
my
all political and diplomatic efforts
aimed at bringing an end to the
escalation and achieving an agreement
for a lasting peace between the parties
thank you
[Music]
i thank the representative of gabon for
his statement i now give the thought to
the representative of united arab
emirates
mr president
i would like to thank director general
grossi for his valuable briefing
the united arab emirates is deeply
alarmed by recent events at and near the
zephorosia nuclear power plant including
the reported damage to critical
infrastructure the external power supply
system
and rate the radiation sensors
these developments illustrate the
disastrous ramifications of the ongoing
conflict not just for ukraine but for
the wider region and the world
when it comes to nuclear matters our
collective security is truly intertwined
a miscalculation a mistake a reckless
act could result in a humanitarian and
environmental catastrophe that would
affect millions of lives
in this context it is crucial that the
iaea have full
unimpeded access to the site in order to
assess the damage and ascertain the
safety of the facility
we support the seven pillars of nuclear
safety and security outlined by director
general grossi in the beginning of march
and remind parties of their importance
in maintaining the safe operation of the
zaparosia plant and other facilities
that may be caught up in the conflict
we further recall the special
protections for nuclear power facility
facilities under international law
including article 56 of additional
protocol 1 to the geneva conventions
which makes clear
that works or installations containing
dangerous forces
including
nuclear generating stations shall not be
made the object of attack even where
these objects are military objectives
these facilities are protected under
international law for a reason
not only are they critical civilian
infrastructure but there are also
immense risks to human life when nuclear
facilities become vulnerable due to
conflict
ensuring the safety of nuclear
facilities is therefore of the utmost
importance and is a critical issue for
the uae
mr president
with the agreement on agricultural
exports we witness the potential for
positive developments when backed by
active and involved diplomacy and broad
international support
the high stakes of nuclear safety and
security and the international
communities manifest concern
should therefore make this a focus of
constructive and necessary engagement
between the parties
these efforts can in turn pave the path
for a broader settlement that ends this
devastating conflict
we therefore reiterate the need for
ongoing dialogue to bring the conflict
to a peaceful sustainable resolution in
a way that is consistent with the un
charter and international law
we re-emphasize the importance of
achieving a cessation of hostilities
throughout ukraine
the alarming developments at zapporosia
underline the urgency of finding a
diplomatic end to this conflict which
continues to cause a staggering
humanitarian crisis in ukraine
despite the difficulties facing this
council
we must work towards fulfilling its
mandate and take incremental and
pragmatic steps to prevent further
suffering
i thank you mr president
i thank the representative of uae for
this statement i now give the floor to
the representative norway
thank you mr president
let me start by thanking director
general grossi for his briefing and for
providing frequent factual updates on
matters within the agency's mandate
the director general has outlined seven
indispensable pillars for nuclear safety
and security
we note with great distress that the
russian forces have violated several of
them during their military aggression
against ukraine
normally norway strongly condemns
russia's illegal and unprovoked invasion
of ukraine which has gone on for half a
year
president
in march the iaea board of governors
adopted a resolution deploring the
russian federation's forcefully seizing
control of nuclear facilities
the board expressed
and i quote grave concern that the
russians federation's aggression is
impeding the agency from fully and
safely conducting safeguards
verification activities at ukrainian
nuclear facilities unquote
we call on russia to return full control
of all ukrainian nuclear facilities
to their ukrainian operators
the ongoing war has disrupted direct
communication lines between them and the
ukrainian regulator this is extremely
dangerous
nuclear safety and security deteriorate
from the presence of an armed aggressor
the staff operating the facilities are
under psychological and physical stress
and they are at the mercy of an invading
force
this is not conducive to the safe
operation of nuclear facilities
norway has had a long-standing
cooperation with ukraine on nuclear
safety and security
and we commend ukraine for its
commitment and dedication to ensuring
continuing nuclear safety and security
in the country under these severe
circumstances
precedent
damage to and destruction of civilian
infrastructure is an unacceptable
it must always be protected in
accordance with international
humanitarian law
we are concerned that russia's
occupation of nuclear power plants in
ukraine means also ceasing control over
the central sources of electricity for
the ukrainian civilian population
in closing precedent norway again
underlines that the russian federations
must immediately withdraw as forces from
ukraine's international recognized
borders and cease all threats and
military actions
this would restore ukraine's abilities
to ensure safe and secure operations at
nuclear facilities
thank you
i think
they represented no way for the
statement i now give the floor to the
representative of brazil
thank you
mr president i thank director barasi for
his clear and comprehensive briefing
brazil has been following with great
concern
news about recent shelling incidents at
the facilities of saprolegia nuclear
power plant near in ukraine
as unanimous
recognized
by the i
iaea
general conference any armed attack on
and threat against nuclear facilities
devoted to peaceful purposes constitutes
a violation of the principles of the un
charter
international law and the institute of
the agency
we reiterate that all parties concerned
have a responsibility
to ensure compliance with the applicable
instruments on nuclear safety and
security
including the convention on nuclear
safety
the joint convention on the safety of
spent fuel
and the convention on the physical
protection of nuclear material and its
amendment
mr president
during the ongoing npt review conference
state parties have been insisting on the
need to promote nuclear safety and
security
as well as risk reduction
the urgency of translating those words
into action
is increasingly evident
while the iea
assessment
that there was no immediate threat to
nuclear safety as a result of saturday's
incident give us some relief
we cannot lose sight of the fact that
recent events have breached virtually
all the seven pillars outlined by the by
the director general rafael grosse
earlier this year
the absence of immediate threat
does not mean the absence of threat
it only means that the parties still
have a chance to avoid a disaster
mr president
what makes the situation so alarming is
precisely the fact that we are fully
aware of the catastrophic and lasting
consequences for human health
and the environment that any damage to
the zapuric
power plant would entail
we therefore call on all parties to
refrain from any measure that could
jeopardize the safety and security of
the npp
as well as its safe operation
as the g rossi recently states
the current situation is attainable
we echo the calls for the deployment of
an
iaea expert mission to the zaporizia npp
without delay and i thank you
i thank you for your statement and i'll
give the form to the representative of
albania
mr president we thank the iaea director
general
grossi for his information his
clarifications and for his leadership
he was crystal clear during his address
at the journal debate of the 10th npt
conference still going on as he was
today
iaea should be fully involved everywhere
in ukraine in order to help prevent a
nuclear disaster there he must be
listened to and his request must be met
colleagues there would not be a meeting
of the council and we would not be
discussing this issue if it wasn't for
the russian invasion of ukraine if this
unjustified and senseless war that is
continuing to this hour had not started
we and the entire world are now familiar
with its disastrous impact on every
aspect of human life and activity
including as feared more than once with
increased nuclear risks with potentially
disastrous consequences
isn't it ironic that while the 10th
review conference of the npt is underway
and the entire world hopes for tangible
progress
on the three pillars of the npt we need
sadly to talk about a persistent serious
risk and nuclear plant in ukraine which
threatens ukraine and its population but
not only
its neighboring countries but also the
european continent and beyond
let me recall one fundamental fact that
is way more than a curiosity
until russia's invasion of ukraine no
nuclear plant has been
ever attacked
overrun
occupied and reportedly militarized by
an invading army
it is the first time that this is
happening as a result of russia's war of
choice and it has created one of the
worst precedents
there is countless evidence that russian
forces have been and continue to conduct
their ugly war requestly and with
brutality
there is a legitimate concern therefore
that russian forces may directly or
indirectly cause a serious or severe
nuclear accident and
take other actions that may result in
the exposure of ukraine's population to
higher
ionizing radiation all while accusing
the victims
of such others of as victims of such
actions
such dreadful concerns have been
validated by the shelling of a nuclear
research institute in kharkiv
as well as by overrunning and occupying
europe's biggest nuclear power station
at zapposia
in the course of the last six months of
the war russia has carried out
indiscriminate ground and air attacks
upon civil infrastructure at residential
areas causing thousands of innocent
victims
further
cyber warfare against targets in ukraine
including electric power grid
installations and systems have
reportedly been linked with russian
actors and interests
making full clarity on the situation on
the power plant in japanesia is critical
and this must be carried out through the
international eyes meaning the iaea
missions
colleagues
russia's actions constitute a serious
and responsible irresponsible breach of
nuclear safety rules and are another
example of its blatant disregard for
international law and international
norms
they undermine the iaea's ability to
monitor ukraine's peaceful nuclear
activities for safeguarding purposes
as rightly stated by the g7 foreign
ministers recently and i quote it is
russia's continued control of the plan
that endangers the region
therefore the longer the war continues
the greater the likelihood that
additional nuclear challenges and risk
may arise related to the need of
ukraine's nuclear regime program for
equipment maintenance and other related
issues which would not be conducted
normally just because of the war
albania reiterates its full and
continued support for the iaea and for
its staff to be able to access all
nuclear facilities in ukraine
safe and without impediment and engaged
directly and without interference with
ukrainian personnel responsible for the
operation of these facilities
the safety of all individuals
implementing those
efforts must be addressed to strengthen
nuclear safety security and safeguards
in ukraine
albania condemns any act of violence
perpetrated inside or near the japanese
nuclear power plant or against its
personnel
ukrainian personnel operating the plant
and the russian occupation must be able
to carry out their important tasks
without restriction threats or pressure
unfortunately as we have seen the seven
safety pillars essential to maintaining
safety nuclear and secure nuclear safety
and security defined at the start of the
war by the iaea have all been
compromised at the zapariza nuclear
power plant
we reiterate our call on the russian
federation to stop the war and
immediately withdraw all its armed
forces from ukraine nuclear facilities
and from the entire ukrainian territory
let me conclude like others because it's
important mr president by recalling what
director general grossly has said
repeatedly including
at the ga if an accident occurs at the
japanese nuclear power plant we will
have
we will not have a natural disaster to
blame we'll only have ourselves to
answer to
actually we know who is to be blamed but
we hope we will never come to it
and for this there is need for concrete
action since inaction is unconscionable
nuclear safety should not be compromised
it should not be politicized and it
should not be used for military tactic
advantages
this is not a time for empty words for
biased narratives or blame game but for
the immediate and strict application of
the iaea safety procedures and protocols
in ukraine i thank you
i thank you for your statement and i'll
give the floor to the representative of
the president
let me begin by thanking director
general rafael grossi for his update
focusing on the safety and security
of nuclear facilities in ukraine
we continue to carefully follow
developments regarding the safety and
security of ukraine's nuclear power
reactors and facilities
india attaches high importance
to ensuring the safety and security of
these facilities as any accident
involving nuclear facilities could
potentially have serious consequences
for public health and the environment
we also accord high priority to the
discharge by the international atomic
energy agency of its safeguards and
monitoring activities in accordance with
its statute in an effective
non-discriminatory and efficient manner
and we value the efforts of the agency
in this regard
we have noted the latest information
available with regard to the nuclear
power plants and facilities in ukraine
including the updates published on 9 and
10 august by the iaea
as well as today's updates on latest
developments
india expresses its concern over the
reports of shelling
near the spent fuel storage facility of
the zapariza nuclear power plant
we call for mutual restraint
so as not to endanger the safety and
security of nuclear facilities
mr president
india continues to remain concerned over
the situation in ukraine
since the beginning of the conflict
india has consistently called for an
immediate cessation of hostilities and
an end to violence
we've called upon both sides to return
to the path of diplomacy and dialogue
we support all diplomatic efforts to end
the conflict
while we are discussing the nuclear
dimension of this conflict
we need also to be acutely cognizant of
the impact of the ukraine conflict on
developing countries
particularly on the supply of food
grains
fertilizer and fuel
it is important for all of us to
appreciate the importance of equity
affordability and accessibility when it
comes to food grains
open markets must not become an argument
to perpetrate inequity and promote
discrimination
in this regard we welcome the
secretary-general backed initiative to
open the export of grains from ukraine
via the black sea and the facilitation
of the exports of russian food and
fertilizers
these efforts
demonstrate that differences can be
resolved through sustained dialogue and
diplomacy
which has been the consistent position
of intel
finally mr president
we would continue to reiterate that the
global order should be anchored on
international law
the u.n charter
and respect for the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of nation
states
thank you
i thank you for your statement i give
the floor to the representative of kenya
thank you mr president
i thank mr crossy director general for
of the iaea for his briefing
we are having a discussion
on the backdrop of the 10th review
conference of the
parties of npt happening
in these premises
the objective
of this treaty is to prevent the spread
of nuclear weapons
and weapons technology
promote cooperation in
the peaceful uses of nuclear energy and
further
the goal of achieving nuclear
disarmament and general
complete disarmament
we are all alive to the fact that
the use of these weapons whether
intentional or accidental
can have an apocalyptic effect on
humanity
biodiversity and the environment
kenya therefore reaffirms its belief
that the total elimination of nuclear
weapons remains the only absolute
guarantee against the use or
threat of use of nuclear weapons
in this regard
we are deeply concerned by the reports
of shelling of ukraine's separation
nuclear power plant
we note with relief that no damage was
caused to the reactors themselves
nor was there any radiological release
or reports of injuries
fully aware of the catastrophic effects
of a stray or deliberate targeting of
such an installation
we urge the need to safeguard the seven
independent
indispensable pillars of nuclear safety
and security as echoed by the director
general
we further urge the parties to refrain
from any military action
that could jeopardize nuclear safety
and security in ukraine
it is also essential that the iaea be
allowed to send a mission
of nuclear safety security and
unsafe guards experts
to the site as soon as possible to
conduct safeguards
verification activities
mr president
beyond the dangers posed by
an insecure nuclear
power plant kenya remains concerned by
the unabated strikes and shelling in
various parts of ukraine
with no meaningful ceasefire in sight
this war continues to cause untold
suffering to the ukrainian people
it also threatens
to usher in a new era of major global
war
kenya continues to call for restraint
from any
actions that may further escalate the
situation
and we reiterate the need to shift focus
to an immediate
cessation
and the deployment of available
diplomatic
tools
such cessation
should set the foundation for the
negotiation of a lasting peace
settlement that guarantees the
sovereignty
territorial integrity
of ukraine
while taking into consideration the
security concerns of russian
federation
finally mr president i reaffirmed
kenya's respect for the sovereignty
and territorial integrity
of ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders i thank you
sheisha
mr president
and unjustifiable aggression
the presence and presence and actions of
the russian armed forces near the plant
significantly
risky
an accident with potentially devastating
consequences russia bears the
responsibility for this situation
full control over the region nuclear
plant as well as all other ukrainians
as underscored by the secretary
without threat or pressure
of nuclear safety and security
with safeguards that are also
compromised by russia's actions this
must be restored that's why i would like
to
understand allowing an idea
of experts
this mission must focus on nuclear
safety and security and enable the
necessary inspections
the mission should be conducted
full respect for the full sovereignty
and its infrastructure
beyond that the iaea personnel should
have access to all ukrainian nuclear
facilities safely and unhindered the
agency must be able to directly and
without interference communicate with
ukrainian staff in charge of running the
position
mr president reiterates
unless the independent sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
in february we have born in the
devastating human cost of the russians
russia must immediately withdraw
from the supreme court
and hold its dangerous charge headlong
charge in the country thank you
i thank the representative of france for
her statement i give the floor to the
representative of mexico
as
rafael rafael marian
for his
critic
situation of the year
nuclear
separation is
[Music]
is
specifically why we completely
unambiguously
any attack on nuclear facilities is
unacceptable
[Music]
established
general conference in 2009.
international
including the 1949 geneva convention
[Music]
for failing to comply with it
the prevailing situation in zapposia
over the last few days
is part of a deplorable pattern of
attacks on civilian infrastructure
mexico calls for
we are facing a real
risk of a nuclear disaster
humanitarian consequences of such a
disaster would be catastrophic both for
human health and for the environment
obstacles nor conditions must be imposed
to enable such inspections to take place
such a mission
would provide us with objective accurate
and independent information
development
leading to a cessation of hostilities
thank you president
i thank the representative from mexico
for his statements i keep the floor to
the representative ireland
thank you president and i would like to
thank director general grossi for his
briefing
the iaea has an indispensable role in
supporting ukraine to ensure nuclear
safety and security at all facilities in
that country especially since russia's
invasion and you have our full backing
in your work
president ireland is deeply concerned by
the situation at the zaparija nuclear
power plant and the strong risk of a
radiological accident or incident
arising from military activity at the
site
such an incident could have devastating
consequences for the people of ukraine
who have already suffered so much from
the actions of the russian federation
it would also have serious consequences
for the wider region
let us make no mistake
the issues at zappourisia arise solely
from the unjust and unprovoked war waged
by russia against ukraine
the reckless actions of the russian
military forces in ukraine have already
demonstrated their utter disregard for
nuclear safety and security
including in their violent illegal
seizure and occupation of the zaparisia
facility
their actions raise real fears of a
significant radiological chemical or
biological accident in ukraine
director general grossi has previously
set out the basic principles of nuclear
safety and security that should be
respected
we call on russia
and indeed all states
to commit themselves to these seven
pillars of nuclear safety and security
regarding peaceful nuclear facilities
and materials in all circumstances
including in situations of armed
conflict
president while we meet here today in
other parts of this building
delegates are gathered for the review
conference on the treaty of the
non-proliferation of nuclear weapons
the npt forms the cornerstone of the
international nuclear disarmament and
non-proliferation architecture
russia's actions in ukraine risk
undermining all three pillars of work
under this important treaty
we urge the russian federation not to
violate or undermine such essential
multilateral instruments upon which our
collective security depends
president in calling for today's
discussion
russia is seeking to avoid its
responsibilities
and to distract from what is really
happening because of its unjustified and
unprovoked war on ukraine
we again urge the russian federation to
stop using the security council to try
to advance its campaigns of
disinformation
if russia is serious about safety at the
zaparica nuclear power plant
what it needs to do is clear end its
illegal occupation of the site
withdraw its troops and munitions so
that the ukrainian authorities with the
iaea can uphold their responsibilities
for safety and security at the site
the iaea board of governors has also set
this out in its resolution at its
special session in march
finally president ireland calls again on
russia to end its brutal war against the
ukrainian people and withdraw its troops
from the entire internationally
recognized territory of ukraine and to
respect the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of its neighbors thank you
thank you for statement i now give the
floor to the representative of the uk
thank you president
and thank you director general grossi
for briefing us once again on the
situation in ukraine
the united kingdom remains deeply
concerned about the ongoing impacts of
russia's illegal invasion of ukraine and
in the context of today's meeting its
effects on nuclear safety
the council discussed russia's reckless
actions at the ukrainian nuclear
facilities
including chernobyl and zapposia at the
start of the invasion
on the 3rd of march the iae board of
governors adopted a resolution calling
for russia to cease all actions against
and at all nuclear facilities in ukraine
so that the competent ukrainian
authorities could regain full control
and ensure their safe and secure
operation
and the iaea could resume their
important safeguards verification
activities
now
over five months later
russia's control of the zapariza plant
continues
the competent ukrainian authorities and
iaea inspectors are still prevented from
properly carrying out their essential
duties
as director general grocery has said
russia's actions have violated almost
all of his seven pillars of nuclear
safety and security
russia's actions are contrary to the
principles of the convention on nuclear
safety and other international nuclear
safety conventions
and they put it jeopardy the safety of
millions
who would be affected by a nuclear
incident in ukraine
president in light of this
and despite russia's continuous
continued lies and obfuscation in this
chamber
about its brutal and irresponsible
assault
we should be clear
it is russia's continued invasion
and military presence that is putting up
the plant at risk
and thereby endangering the local
population the wider region
and the entire international community
president we welcome director general
grace's efforts to strengthen nuclear
safety and security in ukraine in
challenging circumstances
and the tireless heroic efforts of the
ukrainian nuclear facilities staff
despite the immense pressure they are
under
we reiterate our call for iaea
inspectors to be permitted access to all
nuclear facilities in ukraine
to address nuclear safety
security and safeguard concerns
in a manner that respects ukraine's
sovereignty over its territory and
infrastructure
in this regard we note with appreciation
from mr calabro's letter to mr gracie
and the secretary general on this issue
and we once again call on russia
immediately to withdraw its forces from
ukraine
and return full control
of all ukraine's nuclear facilities to
their rightful sovereign owner
to ensure their safe and secure
operation
thank you
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for a statement i shall now make
a statement in my capacity as the
representative of china
colleagues
china has been closely following the
issue of the safety and security of the
nuclear facilities ukraine and is deeply
concerned by the recent attack on the
zaporizia nuclear power plant according
to the information obtained
by the iea from ukraine's nuclear
regulator the attack did not pose an
immediate threat to nuclear safety
and the radiation level remained normal
nevertheless the attack did cause damage
to the physical integrity of the plant
its safety and security system power
supply and personnel safety
unsounded a nuclear alarm to the
international community
the safety and security of nuclear sites
must not be subject to trial and error
this parochial nuclear power plant is
one of the largest such plant in europe
if a large-scale accident occurs at this
plant the consequences would be more
devastating than that of the fukushima
nuclear accident the leakage of massive
quantities of radioactive materials
caused by the fukushima nuclear disaster
and the resulting nuclear contaminated
water have far-reaching consequences
repercussions for the marine environment
food safety and human health thereby
sparking widespread interest and concern
china does not want to see the same
risks playing out again we call on the
party's concern to exercise restraint
act with caution refrain from any action
that may compromise nuclear safety and
security and spare no effort to minimize
the possibility of accidents
china always supports the iaea's active
role in promoting nuclear safety and
security
and performing a safeguards duties in
strict accordance with its mandate
we have noted that director general
garcia and the iaea team of experts have
been planning to visit the project
nuclear power plant
secretary general guterres has also
issued an appeal for this purpose
russia has undertaken to provide
necessary assistance to the visit
we are also aware that ukraine in its
letters to director general crossy under
secretary general guterres dated august
9th
underscored the increasing necessity
of organizing such a visit
we hope that existing obstacles can be
cleared as soon as possible so that the
mission by director general gossi and
iea team of experts can materialize
without delay and they will be able to
conduct their work without impediment
colleagues
the ukraine crisis has been dragging on
for over five months
the security risks posed by the conflict
to nuclear facilities are looming large
throughout only by defusing the
situation and restoring peace at an
early date can we fundamentally remove
nuclear risks reduce misjudgment and
avoid accidents
once again we call on all parties
concerned
to
resume negotiations as early as possible
seek a solution to the ukraine crisis in
a cool-headed and rational fashion
each other's legitimate security
concerns
build a balanced effective and
sustainable
security architecture
so as to achieve common security
it is china's consistent position that
the purposes and the principles of the
entirety should be upheld state
sovereignty and territory integrity be
respected we call upon
all parties in the international
community to act responsibly to
facilitate a proper solution of the
crisis
[Music]
and step up political and diplomatic
efforts in order to create conditions
for the protagonists to return to the
negotiating table china will continue to
play a constructive role in this regard
to the representative of the russian
federation
[Music]
[Music]
um it seems that we alone created any
risks
faulty logic
um
when discussing all sorts of subjects
around ukraine that is to say to in a
coordinated fashion blame russia for
everything that is happening within the
zone of hostilities and any even
hypothetical
events in criminals have disappeared
from the radar where more than 50 people
were killed in a railway station
multiple launch rocket systems
rocket launcher with a ukrainian
military serial number and that can't be
refuted
the recent amnesty international report
and that's an
what we have organization at every
meeting on ukraine since the beginning
of the special military operations
ukrainian armed forces and ukrainian
nationalist battalions are using the
civilian population as a human
and using residential buildings and
firing points deploying heavy weaponry
and artillery in hospital schools
what um
um
it's like the saying uh either say
something good i don't say anything at
all
are they good or nothing either good or
nothing not practical it is
is
it does not chime with your narrow
mercantile geopolitical interests which
is the powers
in the case of this nuclear power plant
we have seen
the the western version of events played
out in western lines
is
irresponsibility of
to
put these questions before the face of
common sense but is
residents of european states hostages
responsibility for that lies among
others with you ladies and gentlemen
with requests that the u.n secretary
are able to give a sober assessment
situation we hear
russia is not using
infrastructure and using civilians as a
humanist
russian
soldiers ensure the protections
of nuclear power plants and days after
today they were repelling attacks
against this object as i already said in
close coordination
is
monstrous provocations thank you
thank you
the representative of the united states
has asked for the floor to make a
further statement you have the floor
ah yes thank you mr president um i will
be brief i don't really want to repeat
everything that i have already said
before
i just want to again appeal to russia
to end this seizure of this alpharesia
power plant and return control of the
facility to the government of ukraine we
will then see how quickly stability
returns to the facility
thank you mr president
thank you
[Music]
of the united kingdom
thank you mr president i will also be
brief um
so to call the spader spade let's just
be very clear here there would be no
risk to nuclear safety without the
illegal invasion of ukraine by russia
an invasion that has caused countless
civilian lives
and an incident at a nuclear facility
which exists precisely because russia
has carried out that invasion thank you
thank you
[Music]
rules of procedure i'm going to
give the floor to the representative of
ukraine
well thank you mr president
distinguished members of the security
council
and i also recognize here the
representative of terrorist russia in
the permanent seat of the soviet union
just half a year ago
one could hardly imagine
a situation when the biggest nuclear
power station
in europe
is ceased following an armed attack
with the use of tanks and artillery
and then packed with military personnel
and weaponry
the weaponry that is used to shell
ukrainian cities
and villages across the
river
it is a matter of alarm
that in order to divert attention from
these practices
russia
has resorted to dangerous provocations
staged shelling of the npp itself
the russians are well known for their
elaborate plans of deceit
sabotage and cover-ups
like the one we witnessed today
a conclusion one may draw from today's
torrent of deception by the russian
envoy
is that when they realized that their
plan had collapsed like a house of cards
russia decided to go for broke
and call for this meeting
this call looks especially cynical
considering their most recent attack on
the facility
which happened earlier today
and directly endangered both the planned
facilities and personnel
i would like to thank director general
grossi for his briefing
he has provided us with a comprehensive
update on the current situation that
makes it clear
that the only way to ultimately remove
the nuclear threats stemming from the
illegal russian presence
at the nuclear power plant
is the withdrawal of the russian troops
and the return of the station to the
legitimate control of ukraine
mr president ukraine highly appreciates
the efforts of the iaea
and the u.n to ensure the safety and
security of the ukrainian nuclear
facilities against the backdrop of the
russian invasion
a zaparisia npp
has been occupied since march the 4th
with his personnel working at gunpoint
ukraine has been in close consultation
with the iaea
about the meta
we have always underlined the importance
of the full and consistent
implementation by the agency of its
mandate
in this regard since the beginning of
russia's occupation of znpp
ukraine has insisted on the need to send
a mission
to decide
and negotiated its modalities with the
agency
we deeply regret therefore
that such a visit has not yet taken
place
due to the destructive russian position
despite their public declarations
the occupiers have resorted to
manipulation and unjustified conditions
on the mission's visit
as well as shelling of the zed npp
and an ergodark thus making the visit
impossible so far
we strongly reject the attempts by
russia
to escape responsibility for the delay
by blaming ukraine by blaming the united
nations secretary general
by blaming the u.n secretariat
was the case not only today but also
with the russian foreign ministry
statement of august the ninth
this prompted ukraine's foreign minister
coleba to reiterate the extreme
importance
of conducting the agency's lead
international mission
to decide
in its letter to the agency's director
general
and the u.n secretary general sent on
august the 9th
we welcome the readiness of the agency's
director general expressed during this
briefing
to send the mission
led by the agency
to the occupied znpp
which should be conducted in strict
compliance with the national legislation
of ukraine
and with full respect of its
international obligations
we stand ready to provide the mission
with all necessary assistance
and facilitate its travel
through ukrainian controlled territory
ladies and gentlemen
let it be known
that the distance
between ukraine's control bank of the
nipper river
and this upper asia npp
that sees on the opposite side of the
river
is
five miles
five miles
beat from nicole
or from margaret's
if russia stops shelling these cities
what in the world will prevent the
mission
to cover
these
five miles
in light of the continued
militarization of the zad npp
site by the russian armed forces
its shelling and subsequent damage to
and mining of certain areas of the site
it is imperative that such a mission has
qualified experts
in the military dimension
this can be achieved
by including those experts in the
mission team
ukraine also sees a lot of added value
in drawing upon relevant and extensive
u.n political expertise
the representatives will be able to make
a significant contribution
to the preparation of the mission's
final report
thus outlining the military dimension of
the critical threats and challenges to
nuclear safety security
and safeguards at the zad npp site
stemming from its occupation and
militarization
by the russian armed forces
mr president it is absolutely clear that
the private provocative russian
practices of shelling the zad npp
and the city of nergadar pose an
unprecedented threat to nuclear security
for ukraine
europe and the war and the world as a
whole
russia must strictly abide by the laws
and customs of all
including
those relating to nuclear facilities
the shelling that took place on august 6
shed light on how these provocations are
arranged
in particular
russian occupants
present at the site
at the time of the shelling
in total about 500 soldiers
and ross atom representatives
took shelter in advance
before the shelling began
while the local employees
were wondered
it also speaks volumes
that the that russian military hardware
deployed at the npp was hidden
in the powerhouses
at the first and second reactors
the shelling damaged three radiation
monitoring detectors had the dry spent
fuel storage facility site
which made impossible
early detection and timely response
in the event
of deterioration of the radiological
situation or release of radiation from
the spanned fuel containers
on august the 7th
the russian armed forces again
restored to resorted to shelling the
zapa regia npp site and damaged the 750
kilowatt kilowatt overhead line
znpp kohovska
substation
as a result of the shelling
a safety trip was activated at one
of the power units
currently this power unit is being
cooled down
consequently there is only one remaining
direction of power delivery at the
zaparisia npp
should this last line be damaged
the zapa regia npp will be totally the
energized
russian plants regarding the zapa regia
npp
aim
at disconnecting it
from the energy system of ukraine
and cutting off electricity in the south
of the country
earlier the russian occupiers also mined
the zaparisia npp outside
the cooling pond and the banks of
kahovka reservoir
which borders the plant
moreover the russian armed forces are
using the plant as cover for shelling
the ukraine control cities located on
the opposite side of the nipple river
especially margaret's and nicoball
with multiple launch rocket systems
under these circumstances
the ukrainian personnel of the zapa
regia npp continue to do their best
to ensure nuclear and radiation safety
as well as to mitigate the consequences
of the russian shelling
dear colleagues
let me underline that the russian
actions
at and against apparition npp
completely violate
practically all seven
indispensable pillars of safety and
security outlined
by the director general at the meeting
of the agency board of governors on the
2nd of march
we demand that russia fully implement
the resolution of the
agency board of governors dated march
the 3rd
the safety security and safeguards
implications of the situation in ukraine
russia must immediately seize
all actions against nuclear facilities
in ukraine
and return control
over all sea's nuclear facilities to the
ukrainian side
the international community must
continue political pressure on the
aggressive state of russia
and demand full and unconditional the
occupation of the zad npp
ensuring the safety and security of
nuclear facility
cannot be
seen as a goodwill gesture
this is the duty
of an occupying power
in accordance with international
humanitarian law
now let me explain it to the russian
ambassador
in the simplest way
step
by step
in a way that even a school kid could
understand
first
state it loud and clear
that russia allows
an iaea led mission
immediately and unconditionally
do not obstruct the trip of five miles
across the river
second
demand the facilities of the zed npp
third
remove your military personnel
and withdraw your weaponry
enough games
dear colleagues
none of us can stop the wind
if it carries
radiation
but together we are capable
of stopping a terrorist state
and the sooner we stop russia
this sooner europe and the world will be
able
to feel
safe again
thank you
thank you for your statement
i would suggest that you look again at
our statements
it says everything very clearly
i would like to draw attention to
something else
even the backers of kiev doubt
that i said that it was absolutely
work and i would like to see
your attention to this statement by the
ukrainian side for the report as it were
thank you
she's here
thank you for statement
director general mr grossi
wishes to make a brief statement before
the conclusion i now give him the floor
thank you very much mr president uh for
giving me the opportunity uh
for a very very uh
closing remark i want to thank all
members of the council for their
interventions which are very important
for us at the iaea to comprehend to
understand even better how they see
things and of course
it is not a rabbit to get into the
political considerations
and we recognize the obvious differences
that exist
but there is something very important
that i at least personally take from
this medium that is a common denominator
here in this room there in new york
everybody agrees
that nuclear safety and security must be
preserved
everybody agrees and supports the seven
pillars for nuclear safety and security
and everybody believes that this mission
must take place so it's no longer a
matter of if
it's only a matter of when
the when must be as soon as possible
it's only the health
that needs to be addressed and i as i
indicated in my initial
briefing i am consulting and i will be
intensifying
my consultations
with ukraine
with the russian federation of course
the united nations to the united nations
department for safety security has been
involved in all of this so we can
conduct the mission which is so badly
needed and i will be of course after
that or at any other moment mr president
at the disposal of the security council
to continue briefing on our
function our mission to support ukraine
this important power and to restore
complete
safety and security around all the
facilities
in the country i thank you very much for
this opportunity
that's it i'd like to thank once again
director gracie for your statements and
qualifications
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers
the meeting is returned
so
thank you
stick off that's it